speaking of uh trustworthy and qualified
doctors though as we show you dr ja
uh here is dr fauci on fox news this
weekend and brett bear did a fine job
smacking him down as you mentioned he's
twice vaccinated twice boosted still got
infected the message you know over the
past couple of days really the past
couple of months is that
listen everybody's going to get this uh
take a listen
people are vaccinated and boosted
sooner or later as we begin to live with
it virtually everybody is going to wind
up getting exposed and likely get
infected this is this is uh you know
everyone was at some point everyone's
going to get covet
all right so dr fancy if that's the case
why are there any mandates anymore for
vaccines or masks or anything
well you have to look at it in in
several different pillars of bread when
you talk about the fact that inevitably
if people have to function out in
society given the high degree
of transmissibility
of this virus
it is going to infect someone who
doesn't have a high degree of protection
okay so fauci just says nothing we
discussed where we were going to cut
that clip i mean he just says nothing
yes we all accept that covet exists we
all accept that the flu exists we all
accept it every now and again you twist
your ankle does the government have any
right to mandate you to do anything the
answer to that is no and just remember
it just remember it because when these
these clown people are now masking up
again in los angeles and in san diego
and they're starting to shut things down
again in certain spots in california and
they will do it they will gladly do it
and a certain amount of people they will
get spanked and they will say thank you
sir may i have another but the fact that
fauci even shows up to any of these
cable news shows the man is completely
shameless let's not forget that joe
biden and anthony fauci are both double
vaxxed and have had two
booster shots and they both
got kovid okay and there is despite what
they say and please correct me if i'm
wrong and i will gladly someone in the
comments show me the study somewhere
that shows show me the real study that
over a year's worth of time where they
did true studies on this that if you get
the vaccine that you will not get covid
uh as as strongly that's what that's
what the meme is right i would have been
much sicker if i didn't there's just no
evidence of that there just isn't they
all say it but there's no evidence of it
fauci knows it which is why he always
talks about things in very sort of
amorphous terms right he never actually
talks to you about numbers and ages and
all those things you get well there's a
certain amount of variability in the
mood
anyway here's joe biden a while back not
too long ago actually just a couple
months ago
talking about the unmaxed because
they're devil worshippers
so there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
so we got to make more progress
okay it was never a pandemic of the
unvaccinated i'm unvaccinated you
unvaccinated you unvaccinated you
unvaccinated i know you all are but i
was just freaking out for a second i
thought maybe they got vaccinated i
don't know what you guys do on the
weekend i let you roam free could have
done anything
uh it was never a pandemic of the
unvaccinated personally i have never
been prouder than that i stood up to it
there were many times that i was
pressured in a gajillion different ways
and what a horrific choice uh all sorts
of people had to make i mean people that
were the front line workers right that
were the people that we were told we
need the most uh that then got pushed
into doing it and people didn't want to
lose their jobs and everything else but
the message here is that the hypocrisy
and all of the policies the lockdowns
keeping people out of work keeping
people on zoom making everybody sort of
depressed and not really functioning it
has done major damage